порядку було залучено понад 2,5 тисячі
працівників поліції залучається до цих
пір не всіх неповнолітніх які були
приймали участь в таких заходах були
запрошені до територіальних відділів
поліції з усіма проведені були
профілактичні бесіди як з ними так і
їхніми батьками та роз'яснення вимоги
адміністративної та кримінальної
відповідальності окрім того хочу
зауважити що вже заблокували близько 100
таких каналів поліцейських разом з
кіберполіцією які були саме створені з
метою штучного розкручування молодіжного
руху та дестабілізувати ситуацію
всередині країни наразі оперативних
кіберполіції та інших оперативних служб
встановлюють джерела фінансування та
організаторів таких інформаційних
каналів вже виявлено біля 60
адміністраторів таких
груп та каналів здебільшого якщо
аналізувати підлітків які приходять на
ці збори та адміністратори якісь
працюють ці канали більше всього вони їх
цікаві їх більше цікавить що коїться
навколо цієї ситуації тобто
Спілкуючись з підлітками вони зазначають
що на меті в них не було ніяких
мотивів щодо проведення масових дій Чи
протистоянь між собою більше всього їх
зацікавити інтерес який розвився навколо
цієї ситуації адміністратори каналів їх
створювали аби для того щоб накопичити
аудиторію собі та потім заробляти кошти
з метою за допомогою донатів або продажу
реклами
звичайно аби не дати ворогу провести
інформаційно-психологічну операцію і
використати в наших дітей Ми з вами нам
з вами потрібно скоординувати наші
зусилля
працювати зі з підлітками і з батьками і
наголошувати аби батьки частіше
цікавилися
чим займається їхні діти з ким вони
спілкуються та як проводять дозвілля
Разом з тим в кожній області у нас є
ювенальні поліцейські які вже проводять
і будуть проводити у всіх закладах
освіти профілактичні профілактичні
роботи бесіди з усіма віковими
категоріями учнів щодо небезпеки участі
в таких випадках тому давайте працювати
разом якщо в когось неможливо десь немає
порозуміння якогось ми готові сприяти
цьому і можу запевнити що поліція
відвідує кожен заклад освіти який як
мінімум виявить бажання аби ми туди
завітали і впевнений що разом ми надамо
гідну відсіч державі агресору десь цього
приводу вже хочу сказати що є позитивна
динаміка зменшення створення цих каналів
та участі дітей у цих групах за останні
три дня
ми не допущено жодного такого зібрання і
на сьогодні також за нашою інформацією
поки не де їх не планується тому можемо
користуватись що всі разом ми працюємо
непогано і вже є певні якісь результати
з попередження цього Дякую
Дякуємо Ярослав Вікторович ми дійсно
дуже спільно Працюємо з національною
поліцією України і на рівні Міністерства
і на рівні областей і сьогодні області
теж представлять співпрацю тому що ми
маємо сьогодні всі об'єднати всі зусилля
щоб точно не поширювати такі ігри Я хочу
зараз запросити до слова Катерина
олександрівну гольцбург президента
асоціації дитячих аналітичних психологів
Катерина Олександрівна
Доброго ранку всім
не думала що з мене почнуть я хотіла
почути спочатку мабуть
інших але мені дуже хотілося мабуть
важливо сказати іноді буває так
трапляється от ми психологія це
помічаємо що
коли ми хочемо щось
запобігти чомусь ми можемо навпаки
поширити інтерес серед підлітків з цієї
тематики Тому ми маємо бути вкрай
обережними з певними діями щодо за до
запобігання цьому тому що
на жаль ми Ну мені здається створюємо
іноді цей штучний інтерес і мені как
психологи як психологу дійсно було
цікаво я спілкувалася з підлітками Я
кожного дня працюю з підлітками і так
виявилося що більшість підлітків які
дізналися
про це дізналися не з каналів телеграм А
чи від власних батьків чи із засобів
масової інформації тому мені по-перше
здається важливою
комунікація саме з засобами масової
інформації
як поширювати таку інформацію що з нею
робити Що ми маємо
озвучувати як це озвучувати тому що те
що Я поки що бачу мене трохи турбує як
дитячу підліткового психолога тому що
це більше про
такі покарання більше про покарання а не
про профілактику А мені б хотіли щоб ми
все ж таки звернули увагу на
профілактику і це робота не тільки з
дітьми це по-перше робота з батьками
просвітницька робота як ми психологи
кажемо психоедукація тому що мені
здається вона надважлива тому що я вже
знаю випадків коли саме
дітей підлітків які виглядали
як анімешники вже
публічно били знаю один такий випадок
він зареєстрований і
мені б не хотілося щоб ми створили
спільноти про проти якоїсь спільноти І
мені здається це буде небезпечним це
буде внутрішні якісь конфлікт серед
підлітків А цього точно Ми не хочемо всі
тому мені здається важлива просвітницька
діяльність важливі якісь можливо лекції
про субкультури не тільки просто
позбавити всіх діти дітям властиво
об'єднуватися в комфортні групи
конформізм властивий підліткам як
бажання приєднатися до тих хто мене
розуміє до спільників і тому позбавити
їх цього підлі
ткового підліткової цієї
[музика]
бажання об'єднатися Ми не можемо Але
можливо ми маємо щось зробити дійсно Як
вже було сказано про
патріотичне виховання про те що ми маємо
щось зробити щоб дітям було цікаво
об'єднуватися в спільноти які не несуть
загрози
життю здоров'ю інших людей
ну якщо це так коротко Я б хотіла саме
це сказати тобто комунікація засоби
масової інформації Правильно щоб ми не
породжували не демонізували ніякі речі а
по-друге це скоріш за все
робота
з батьками і підлітками яка не має на
меті якісь покарання А має на меті
з'ясувати що це Навіщо це звичайно Мене
дуже турбує
я писала у себе на сторінці в Фейсбуці
те що цей контент поширюється саме
країною-агресором І тут ми маємо ввести
ще й просвітницьку діяльність з того що
Який контент наші діти
слухають що вони дивляться
і
знов-таки про це можна говорити і це
може бути і педагог і
засоби масової інформації дуже багато
зараз створюється українського контенту
які дуже цікавий такий теж
просвітницький тому
такі поки що в мене думки Дякую що
надали мені слово
Сподіваюся буде рідна робота ми дуже
часто
звертаємо будемо вибудовувати той
алгоритм який дійсно сьогодні ми маємо
правильно як педагоги і психологи
допомогти нашим дітям Дякую
вам також я хочу запросити зараз до
слова начальника відділу психологічного
супроводу та соціально-педагогічної
роботи інституту модернізації змісту
освіти
флярковську Ольгу Василівну Ольга
Василівна ми вас Запрошуємо Доброго
здоров'я колеги
мені не дали право демонструвати
презентацію
[музика]
дякую
Отже щоби я що би мені хотілось сказати
Те що у підлітковому віці дитина
переживає кризу
розвитку і ідентичності і тому для цього
періоду розвитку особистості притаманні
незрілі моральні переконання підвищений
його центризм прояви впертості
протести і поведінки прагнення до
Незалежності ну і багато іншого і
особливості вікового і соціального
розвитку підлітка
актуалізують завдання підвищеної уваги
до формування у них небезпечної
поведінки що є складовою її профілактики
як правильно сказала пані Катерина
її необхідно здійснювати шляхом
просвітницької діяльності педагогів щодо
педагогічної підтримки дитини шляхом
використання потенціалу освітнього
середовища у
безпечному спілкуванні з дітьми у
процесі консультування батьків і для для
того щоб допомогти дитині яка потрапила
у тенета небезпечної субкультури
необхідно насамперед з'ясувати причини
зазвичай першочергової є
незадоволеність існуючої реальністю а
тому важливо з'ясувати що ж саме дитину
незадовільняє чи відсутність друзів
напруженість стосунків з ровесниками з
батьками несприятливі сімейні обставини
і головним тут є те Чим більше ми
приділяємо уваги дитині тим менше буде
ризиків негативного впливу бо діти часто
залучаються до негативних практик тоді
коли не бачать до себе інтересу від
батьків чи інших близьких людей
педагогів і з такими і багатьма іншими
випадками у закладі освіти працюють
фахівці психологічної служби хоча
наголошую що
фахівці психологічної служби працюють в
тісній співпраці із педагогічним
колективом і мають працювати з
педагогічним колективом але на
сьогоднішній день
у нас
практичних психологів
хтось малює мені
практичних психологів у нас 20000 413
чому я озвучую цю цифру тому що
забезпечені фактичними психологія і
соціальних педагогами у нас тільки на
60%. тому я говорю про те що ми маємо в
тісній співпраці з Усім педагогічним
колективом працювати завжди але при
цьому у нас понад 87 звернень з різних
причин
звернення у нас і до і щодо профілактики
шкідливих звичок ви бачите я не буду
озвучувати тому що сказали що мало в
мене часу тому я не буду озвучувати ці
цифри ви їх бачите і так також щодо
групи ризику робота з дітьми
а соціальні прояви поведінки у дітей
стосується дально поведінка дітей
ці дані ми збираємо Кожен рік щорічно у
нас оновлюється всі дані
практичні психологи організовують для
педагогічних працівників суперевізійні
групи ви бачите тематику супервізійних
груп
Я хочу сказати що кожен рік
практичний психологи отримують лист це
такий якщо методичні рекомендації щодо
діяльності психологічної служби
посилання воно активне і якщо вам
потрібно буде презентацією
ми надамо і У вас будуть ці посилання де
ми акцентуємо увагу і на цьому аспекті
роботи хоча ми розрізнюємо всі види
робіт але це це спектр роботи з цими
негативним явищем Ми теж акцентуємо
завжди увагу і завжди прописуємо як
працювати І де брати методичні посібники
методичні літератури стосовно цього
напряму як я вже сказала
забезпеченість практичного психолога у
нас на 60% до 60% соціальному педагогами
взагалі
фахівцями психологічної служби тому
виникла така необхідність створення
додаткової платформи де би могли ті діти
ті педагоги які не має в школі
практичного психолога і соціального
педагога де би вони могли знайти
психологічну підтримку
і де б ви могли ознайомитися або
консультуватися і інститутом
модернізації змісту освіти міністерством
освіти науки України було започатковано
вже два роки тому всеукраїнський проект
профорієнтації побудови кар'єри чому я
про нього говорю тому що на сьогоднішній
день виникли така потреба у
психологічному консультуванні і ми на
цій платформі зараз розробили ще одну
додаткову таку опцію і в нас є
розроблений курс підвищення кваліфікації
стосовно першої психологічної допомоги
курс підвищення кваліфікації можуть
пройти всі педагогічні працівники
наголошую на тому що
першу психологічну допомогу надають не
тільки психологи і соціальний педагоги
першу психологічну допомогу можуть
надавати всі хто пройшов курс підвищення
кваліфікації він у вас є за посиланням
Цей курс ви його можете пройти отримати
сертифікат на один кредит
на цій платформі у нас було дуже багато
розроблено і школа кар'єрного
консультування і також у нас були багато
розроблена всіх інших
напрямів але як центую увагу на тому що
всі педагогічні працівники всі учасники
освітнього процесу можуть пройти
консультування на цій платформі і
отримати
психологічну допомогу в цьому напрямі
інститутом розроблені такі інформаційну
базу професійного інструментарію для
фахівців психологічної служби системи
освіти стосовно всіх напрямів роботи і
безпосередньо корекційно-розвиткова
робота в цьому напрямі ви бачите
програми але їх дуже багато тому Ось
посилання є на цю програму воно всі
посилання живі ви можете потім
переглянути також і профілактичну роботу
здійснюють точно так же як і корекційну
роботу і так же як і діагностичну роботу
в нас всі напрями по роботам у нас всі
вони є всі у нас активні людина може
відкрити подивитися назву відкрити на
методичних посібник чи на тест який і
користуватися безпосередньо вже не може
створена експозиція авторських програм
всеукраїнського конкурсу де ми вибрали
ті роботи які за цим напрямом
вони є але в нас є всі напрями я
акцентую на увагу на тому що є всі
напрями за цим напрямом теж є робота
ведеться факультативи виокремлені
також на допомогу фахівцям психологічної
служби з перших днів
повномасштабної війни Ми розпочали цикл
вебінарів вебінарів продовжуються і
цього часу і для практичних психологів
окремо для соціальних педагогів і
педагогічних працівників окремо всі
вебінари є в записі всі вебінари можна
переглянути їх вже понад 50
на допомогу педагогічним працівника
матеріали розміщені на сайтах інституту
модернізації змісту освіти Також ми
акумулювали такий дайджест в якому всі
активності щодо роботи психологічної
служби
він є електронним можуть заходити всі
фахівці можуть заходити педагогічні
працівники кожен
кожна опція активна Тобто там є
посилання ви нажимаєте на посилання і
ознайомлюйтеся з матеріалами яких які
Вас цікавлять
Також у нас є Facebook сторінка фейсбуку
де ми висвітлюємо свої активності
матеріали
і на останок хочу сказати що бажаю вам
всім вітальної енергії друзі будемо
наближати перемогу як можемо надаючи
підтримку один одному і тим хто цього
потребує
обов'язково переможемо
Ольга Василівна Дякуємо і вашу
презентацію Ми надішлемо всім нашим
учасникам наради якщо ви не заперечуєте
Ні я не заперечую навпаки буду рівні
дуже вдячна Дякую І я хотіла б зараз
запросити до слова співголову
громадської організації батьки
сосперфонову Олену ігорівну вона
Ігорівна Ви маєте бути ми бачимо що ви є
так Добрий день Дякую що запросили
Насправді Я повністю погоджуюсь з пані
Катериною огонь знаєте у нас на
сьогоднішній день день дійсно склалась
така ситуація що ми переходимо від
каральної педагогіки до
педагогіки довіри і вибудовує
партнерських стосунків І от Саме тут що
стосується психологічної служби нам дуже
важливо змінити теж ситуацію тому що в
школі дуже часто батьки зазначають що
щоб не трапилось першим що кажуть
відрахуємо від школи ваше ваша дитина
погана і все але тут же ж важлива
причина і ми бачимо
якщо
ваша дитина погано всі найкращі
дивиться Питання в тому що я озвучую
думку батьків і вони насправді дуже
стурбовані тим що в нас відбувається Так
що якщо щось трапляється одразу
включається Ось така реальна педагогіка
тому що от є випадок треба порушника
наказати і це дуже погано Я вважаю що
саме зараз ми маємо це змінити І дійсно
Це залежить від того контенту який ми
проживаємо який ми даємо дуже величезна
проблема У нас ще й все ж таки з
медіаграмотністю Мені здається що ми на
це теж маємо звернути увагу і вибудова
саме партнерських відносин школи батьки
і дітей - це основа в принципі
в цього нашого спілкування і це дуже
важлива складова освітнього процесу Мені
здається що ми маємо на це звернути
увагу і я вам скажу чесно батьки дуже
за 8 років моєї роботи пісок я вам скажу
що дуже багато коли батьки звертаються
ми їх ми їм там кажемо є проблема
Можливо ви звертались до психолога
можливо психолог працював з класом вони
кажуть так тести були Але ж це не та
робота яку ми маємо вибудовувати і нам
не треба
говорити про погане нам напевно треба
все ж таки давати батькам
інформацію про те що в дитини є і хороші
якісь речі давайте їх підтримувати і
спілкування з батьками це не має бути що
Я начальник ти дурак такого не може бути
на страху ми не вибудуємо ці партнерські
відносини Я просто закликаю всіх що
давайте все ж таки ставати партнерами
Давайте говорити якщо в нас зараз є така
проблема з цією групою то ми не будемо
залякувати дітей розказувати що вас
посадять в тюрму і текст і те ДТП А про
те що це можуть бути негативні наслідки
чому це небезпечно звідки це походить І
дійсно згодна з пані Катериною що ми
маємо все ж таки і зі ЗМІ працювати для
того щоб
ця інформація вона яку ми всі споживаємо
вона була адекватною в цій ситуації тому
що коли було стині микитами Ну я вам
чесно скажу це було просто страшно тому
що кожного чайника лунали ці жахи і все
що було в школі
це було на страху щоб бійтесь це страшно
це а причин цього не було дальше Там
було і меми І що тільки не було Тому
закликаю просто до того щоб ми
вибудували партнерські відносини
довірливі відносини і працювали дітей а
не для того щоб їх карати
дуже вдячна
Дякуємо Олена Ігорівна і ми хотіли би
сказати що Міністерство освіти спільно
із співорганізаторами і батьками сос
відпрацьовують Зараз якраз підготовку
психологів і ми сьогодні бачимо зовсім
іншу психологічну службу Тому це теж
буде сьогодні модернізовано і будемо
займатися сьогодні стратегією
інклюзивної освіти де сьогодні також це
надважливо у нас Я хочу запросити зараз
Київську область щоб вони сказали як
вони працюють цього питання в своїй
області Ярослави Іванівну тростянську
директора Департаменту освіти і науки і
Очеретяного Максима Анатолійовича
Доброго дня в Київській області Так
дякую доброго дня шановні колеги про
ситуацію на Київщині хочу сказати що і
Департамент освіти і відповідні
структури швидко зреагували на те щоб
загальмувати розповсюдження нового
молодіжного руху
наші дії були такі а 28 Ми отримали
інформацію де йшлося про існування
розповсюдження руху і вже на наступний
день Департамент освіти і науки було
направлено лист керівникам місцевих
органів управління освітою
територіальних громад
районних адміністрацій закладом
профтехосвіти фахові передвищої освіти
де зазначалася інформація про цей
молодіжний рух через який соцмережі він
поширюється хто зазвичай є учасником
цього руху де саме збирається підлітки
тощо також до цього листа було
направлено два додатки пам'я тому
батькам як запобігти участі дитини В ЦВК
ридан де детально викладено дії батьків
і взагалі як будувати
взаємовідносини з дитиною яка йому вірно
є учасником цього руху і другий додаток
- це кольоровий попереджувальний пост
для батьків знову ж таки розроблений
поліцією Київщини 3 березня минуло
п'ятницю за участі Київської обласної
військової адміністрації за участю
представників головного управління
Національної поліції в Київській області
було проведено онлайн нараду з головами
районних військових адміністрацій та
голими територіальних громад і також з
керівниками місцевих органів управління
освітою щодо здійснення профілактичних
заходів серед однієївської та
студентської молоді з метою недопущення
їх участі в новому молодіжному руці і за
результатами наради надіслано протокол
учень адміністрації і територіальним
громадам хочу сказати що вже на минулому
тижні проведено спільні наради за участю
голів профільних заступників голів
територіальних громад за участі
представників нацполіції служби безпеки
України місцевих органів управління
освітою та культури де обговорено
профілактичні заходи щодо
нерозповсюдження нового молодіжного руху
керівникам закладів освіти доручено
провести профілактичний заходи із цього
питання проведено також батьківські
збори на яких здобувачів освіти та їхніх
батьків проінформовано про небезпечність
участі в цьому Русі хочу сказати також
що представниками ювенальної поліції
надавалися роз'яснення щодо причин які
спонукають підлітків залучатися до
агресивних субкультур та рекомендації
щодо запобігання вступу та участі в цих
угрупованнях правоохоронці Київщини
також нагадали про правила безпечного
спілкування в соціальних мережах
керівниками закладів освіти проведено
інструктивний наради з педагогічними
працівниками під час яких доручено
здійснити аналіз дозвілля підлітків та
посилити контроль за відвідуванням
занять
також хочу сказати що і У гуртожитках
закладів професійної освіти
соціальної педагоги психологами спільно
з вихователями проведено тематичні
зустрічі інформаційні години із
здобувачами освіти які проживають ці
гуртожитках щодо небезпечності даного
молодіжного руху І зараз хочу слово
надати заступнику начальника головного
управління Національної поліції в
Київській області полковнику поліції
очеретяному Максиму Анатолійовичу
будь ласка Максима Анатолійович Доброго
дня шановні колеги Дякую за нами
можливість поспілкуватися обговорити
таке найважливе питання з чим ми
стикнулися на території Київщини під час
розповсюдження цього молодіжного руху
серед дітей по-перше хотів би зазначити
що починаючи з 27 лютого коли ми
отримали ну загальну інформацію взагалі
по державі
надходила інформація про створення таких
телеграм-каналів розповсюдження
інформації серед молоді ми вже на вечері
мали 10 таких груп які почали виявляти
на території різних районів у нас на
Території Київської Області сім районів
відповідно усіх майже районах Ми бачили
Ці групи
першопочаткова кількість учасників була
фактично 150 приблизно осіб Звісно що
наші дітки
розуміються як користуватися телеграмами
хтось
свій номер телефону приховував хтось ні
але ми бачили що цікавість до цих
телеграм-каналів відповідної взагалі
обговорення інших фабриках ну дуже
зростає вже на ранок
28 Відповідно 1/2 ми бачили велике
зростання кількості цієї групи і
відповідно кількість учасників Ну так
само проаналізувавши динаміку І взагалі
географію розвитку цих створення цих
телеграм-каналів і розповсюдження цієї
інформації Зрозуміло Ну просто річ що ми
маємо тільки великих містах
де розповсюдження таких створення
телеграм-каналів Ну і відповідно
залучення тоді мови
розуміючи цю небезпеку вже починаючи з
28-го з вечора 27-28 почали активно
працювати в навчальних закладах
відповідно
за допомогою
обласної військової адміністрації
відповідно територіальних громад але
проводивши заходи нашої ювенальні
поліцейські поліцейські офіцери громади
дають взагалі ми розуміли що вона не дає
таких результатів Чому тому що діти
дійсно підтримують попередніх глядачів
які зазначають що діти проявляють
цікавість домовляються до цих
телеграм-каналів але на метільно для
себе поставили іншого методу точніше вже
починаючи там з другого
березня і 3 відповідно вже провели такі
онлайн-наради де запровадили на протягом
Суботів неділі відповідно проведення
всіх онлайн-нарад і зустрічі з
батьківськими комітетами відповідно всі
поліцейські за оці два дні фактично в
суботу неділю зустрілись майже з кожним
педагогічним колективом батьківські
зборах Ну все возможно і онлайн і учні
формати були проведені і ми вже на ранок
понеділка мали такі результати роботи як
у нас вже залишилась 520 учасників цих
груп і на сьогоднішній день вже це 144
при цьому тому ж з тридцяти існуючих
Telegram матеріалів починали його
зазначав що з 10 фактично на пікі їх
було 30 і майже
1748 учасників то на сьогоднішній день
вже ми маємо 144 учасника і фактично 6
груп які залишились у нас на території
Київщини Заходи які ми проводили Звісно
що в тісній співпраці з освітянами тому
що ми не підходили до цього питання так
щоб донести до молоді що таке реданно це
погано чи добре ми підходили до того
питання Що роз'яснювали що
розповсюдження культу насильства це
взагалі погано Тим паче що в деяких
випадках ми познаходили все ж таки дітей
які стали адміністраторами і я вам хочу
сказати що
адміністратором Владислав не по своїй
волі і вони просто в пабліках проявляли
як він активну участь і потім не
встановлені особи на сьогоднішній день
їх добавляли робили адміністраторами
провокували їх для того щоб вони робили
заклики для зборів що стосується
відповідно відпрацювання на структури
воно це добре що наші діти прогнозовані
тим паче Що Всі акти які були
розповсюджені на території великих міст
і ми розуміли місця і зборів останні дні
Це наприклад п'ятниця і четверта взагалі
з нами на цих рейдових заходах були
присутні вже і педагоги і громадські
організації які нам допомагали не просто
робити нашу роботу звичайно для нас
профілактувати чи виявляти там дітей на
підлітків Да яких знаходились там на
підпитку як агресивно собі поводили а й
взагалі проводити роз'яснення роботи
тому що ну В цих місцях як завжди
збирається дуже багато на сьогоднішній
день ми маємо з усіх проведених заходів
На минулому тижня у нас було запрошено
44 особи хочу розказати що 33 з них це
неповнолітні але і Повнолітні особи які
своїми діями вони дійсно провокували
тому в кожному районі Відповідно ми
намагалися встановити таких осіб Ну і
відповідно зробити таким чином щоб це
впливали на мовах що стосується інших
заходів ну на сьогоднішній день Ми
продовжуємо цю роботу проводити і
завдяки обласній військово-адміністрації
сприяння всім освітянам в нас виходить
Тому що Ну насправді дійсно
кібербезпека це на сьогоднішній день
вкрай важливо ми підходимо до цього
питання дуже виважемо Тим паче що ми
бачимо що динаміка розповсюдження таких
течій рада Ну та антиретану вже на
Території Київської Області взагалі
майже не спостерігається але готуємось
до нових викликів Тому нам запроваджено
відповідно з погодженням обласної
військову адміністрації продовжувати ці
заходи проводжувати доносити до
підлітків і взагалі до молоді Як себе
вести в цих пам'ятниках тому що ви
повинні розуміти ми проаналізувавши
інформацію окрім 30 кг каналів Чи це все
розповсюджувалося фактично
обговорювалася на різноманітних
[музика]
телеграм-каналах інших там
територіальних громад там де фактично ми
могли якось працювати через по-перше
через батьків тому що і наші методичні
рекомендації пам'ятку для батьків які ми
розробили там відповідне зазначали щоб
вони по-перше звернули увагу на те що є
таке течія а відповідно на те що треба з
дитиною сісти поспілкуватися подивитись
взагалі в яких вона чатах е-е присутня
взагалі яким чим цікавиться і як ми
бачимо останнім часом це Тік токи
фейсбуки які Ну на жаль діти становиться
заручниками розповсюдження такої
інформації бійок директор все інше тому
культ насильства і Відповідно ми всі
разом з вами не дамо розповсюджуватися
ну всі інші заходи які ми проводимо
наступне вже це буде вже
Скажем так спрямовані на
забезпечення їх безпеки попередження
кібербуліно тому що ми розуміємо що на
сьогоднішній день військовий стан дає
можливість дітям більш спілкуватися в
інтернет-магазинах ми відповідно більше
в кіберпросторі вони там більш
комфортніше себе почувають Тому це
комплексний такий підхід і ми не
огранічуємося повністю заходами що
стосуються документів
дзвоніть щоб ми всі підготували до
зустрічі ну
Дякую за увагу
Шановні колеги просимо виключати
мікрофони будь ласка Слідкуйте
Максима Анатолійович Ми вам дуже дякую
тому що ми сьогодні на прикладі Київщини
спілкуємося слухаємо як уже проводиться
робота в регіонах і ми знаємо що наші
колеги і інших регіонах долучилися тому
я зараз запрошую до слова службову Ганну
павлівну директора комунального
позашкільного навчального закладу
кіровоградського обласного центру
дитячої та юнацької творчості
Доброго дня шановні колеги я дуже дякую
Що
Віра Борисівна Міністерство внутрішніх
справ не лишили сам на сам з цією бідою
наших дітей навіть батьків і педагогів
тому що дійсно тільки спільними
зусиллями ми можемо врятувати не одне
покоління дітей чому кажу покоління бо
сьогодні Юлія Василівна казала про те що
етимологія походження якраз
субкультур Вона сягає
не лише цього року а
зрозуміло що
за якого психологію діти
дітям притаманне якраз долучення до
таких культур але Дозвольте розділити
все ж таки на дві складові дане питання
з одного боку це
залучення дітей до субкультур їм участь
точніше і створення цих культур інша
справа технології які ви використовуєте
агресор в інформаційній війні і скажу
про те що і в нашій області зрозуміло і
управління освіти Департаменту освіти і
науки Кіровоградської обласної
адміністрації військової і
юнальним кревенція поліція дуже добре
спрацювали були спроби зрозуміло що і
долучити нашому до цієї технології але
спрацювали достатньо ефективно Я
впевнена що в цьому допомогла
це оперативна реакція на даний момент а
система ще яка була запроваджена
додому скажу про те що дуже ефективна є
наша співпраця кримінальна прогресією ми
ще три роки тому уклали меморандум із
головними управліннями національної
поліції обласного парламенту дітей
обласного центру дитячо-юнацької
творчості і таким чином юні парламентарі
у навчальних закладах у закладах
дошкільної освіти по області стали
такими помічниками інспекторів І дійсно
взаємодіють крім того скажу що якраз
напередодні Донецької університету
внутрішніх справ який Ірина кований до
нашого міста Кропивницького створив
спільну з юнісептики проєкт обшивки і
інкуповий якраз проводили і з нашими
безпосередньо дітями в нашому закладі
навчальному і німецьких навчальних
закладах такі тренінги просвітницькі
кібербезпеки але на даний момент ми
спілкувалися з ними про те щоб із
номінального конвенцією і психологами
було дуже вірно казала і Пані Катерина
ні про те що
інколи інформація подається таким чином
що той хто і не знав цікавиться і хоче
долучитись до того чи іншого процесу по
дійсно ми зараз готуємо тоді на такий
тренінг або
якраз
Курсанти перший другий третій курс який
зовні як мінімум не дуже відрізняються
від старшокласників хоча кримінальна
превенція радить починаючи з 7 класу вже
провести такі тренінгівські
перезабезпеки і саме щоб Курсанти
середньої старшій школі учням якраз
розповіли
особливості не лише даної технології а
взагалі з кібербезпеки провели такі
прямі і з парламентом дітей Також ми
хочемо протестувати такі тренінг що
заходять на що реагуємо молодь на що ні
щоб це була там мова яку підліток почує
це один напрям
з асоціації або за шкільної освіти
влітку в липні підписала також
меморандум із
царство небесної денісом монастирському
Міністерства внутрішніх справ також про
співпрацю Я думаю що це була б дуже
також гарна практика і в інших областях
такої співпраці такою взаємодії це один
момент другий скажу про те що
такі переконаний технології будуть
використовуватись і надалі це така
Ласточка була Перша ластівка значить аби
спробувати як забути насправді У нас
дуже я не скажу в цифрах з цим потрібно
дуже обережним був але вже четвертий з
4-5 класу і старше діти грають в ті ігри
які на мій погляд є для них величезною
загрозою ну з одного боку це залежність
це окреме питання комп'ютерна так ні з
іншого боку хто ми дарує
події ігри Хто Значить
скажу що про те що частину учасників є
якраз представники країни-агресора які
розповідають і подружньому формують
думку формують імпланітет наших дітей
оці три роки
карантину і війни вони
деяких дітей яких Якраз зараз
відбувається процес встановлення
є став вирішальний вони ушли повністю в
інший світ віртуальний світ І вони з
радістю коли такий заклик був
в цих групах
[музика]
Запрошуємо
тобто
працювати зрозумі
ла працює Да Вже
бути чи відбувається але батьків в цьому
віці не дуже слухають тому
слухають педагогів позашкілля ми маємо
зберегти систему знов-таки і де закриття
в нашій області значить є проблеми
звичайно в бюджетом але намагаються
утримати максимальні заклади
шкільної і якраз альтернативою даним
субкультура є позашкільна освіта
підтримайте будь ласка значить і
звичайно психологічна служба це великий
виклик зараз збереження і розвиток
психології навіть дякую
Шановні колеги ми хочемо зараз
представити вам декілька проектів
державних наших центрів позашкільної
освіти це заступник директора
національного центру малої Академії Наук
пещері на Тетяна Вікторівна Вербицький
Володимир Валентинович директор
Національного еколого-натуралістичного
центру учнівської молоді шкура Геннадія
Анатолійович директор учнівського
Українського Державного центру
позашкільної освіти і лісота Андрія
Андрійович директор Українського
Державного центру
національно-патріотичного виховання коли
я був дуже просила дуже стисло в
презентації У вас є ми надішлемо усім
але щоб ми вклалися в регламенту 12
починається наступна нарада прошу
Доброго дня шановні колеги ми сьогодні
готові поділитися тими практичними
напрацюваннями тими кейсами якими маємо
і які стосуються правил інформаційної
безпеки який слід отримав дотримуватися
дітям дорослим при користуванні і
месенджерами і соцмережами інтернетом в
цілому і також розкажемо про проект який
стосується
психології спілкування з дітьми всі ці
проекти вже відпрацьовані Вони вже
пройшли тестування і ми в березні місяці
плануємо старт 20-х числах деяких
проектів які стосуються кібербулінгу
Запрошуємо до участі і завжди відкриті
Якщо вам потрібно буде для вас за вашим
запитом провести
окремий онлайн курс або вебінар або
лекцію то ми готові прийняти вас запит
ми всю інформацію про себе залишимо і
можемо спілкуватися далі з вами і
вирішувати якісь конкретні питання
конкретні проблеми зараз я хочу передати
слово Наталі легкій вона по презентації
пройде по проектах дуже коротенько
Добрий день шановні колеги Мене звати
Наталя легка я представниця
національного центру Мала академія наук
України і зараз я вам коротко для того
щоб не затримувати часу оскільки
презентація буде вам надіслана
презентують ті основні заходи які
національні центри реалізовує його
питання що стосується
кібербезпек які береги гігієни що
питання субкультур як виявляється воно
теж є складовою саме оцього процесу для
того щоб комплексно допомогти Як дітям
так і педагогам ми проводимо
цикли заходів що стосуються цифрової
грамотності зокрема кібергі гігієни
наприклад на освітній платформі у нас
публікуються різні матеріали що
стосуються допомоги як дітям так і
педагогам зараз найближчим часом вийдуть
стаття що стосується як питань порад
психологів
щодо взаємодії з дітьми Не порушуючи її
кордонів
всі курси які вже пропрацьовані і
апробовані але зараз доопрацьовуються
для того щоб окремо
уточнити стосовно питання що стосується
небезпеки які можуть стосуватися
субкультур тобто питання яке
розглядаються на сьогоднішній раді зараз
Ці курси вони допрацьовуються вони
окремо є курс для дітей окремо для
педагогів і Відповідно ми можемо їх
реалізовувати за запитом окремих
закладів освіти це курси основи
кібербезпеки
цикл лекції інформаційна гігієна на
слайдах ви зможете детальніше прочитати
що що саме ми пропонуємо також курс для
педагогів анатомія пропаганди і серія
вебінарів для дітей та педагогів що
стосується кібербулінгу Саме ці нації
вебінари зараз іде реєстрація Ви можете
чи на нашому сайті чи так само через
контакти Які ми які вам будуть надані
Після цієї наради зареєструватися на цей
курс або подати заявку на проведення для
того щоб ми організували проблеми для
конкретної
конкретного заходу чи конкретної громади
який курс що стосується
цифрової цифрових технологій безпеки в
інтернеті та проблем які ми обговорюємо
на сьогоднішній нараді для того щоб не
затримувати час та коротко все
будь-які деталі ми
члени вдома можна звернення
це завершена презентація
Дякуємо
Володимир Валентинович будь ласка
Вітаю Слава Україні Шановні колеги
презентація буде я безперечно хотів
декілька слів перед презентації Ми
мусимо всіх зрозуміти що це зупинити
сьогодні в цю культуру яка рухається по
на Україну
неможливо Ми мусимо зрозуміти щоб ця
субкультура буде рухатися в інших формах
і нам безперечно треба зрозуміти
яким чином
формальної освіти Ми мусимо думати про
те щоб кожний позашкільний заклад мав
упереджувальні дії кіберцентри по
реакції на всі дії субкультур які можуть
їхати рухатись я безперечно хотів би
сказати про те що це залежить не тільки
від тих принципових питань які говорили
попередники А цей залежить від
позашкілля де діти мусять бути зайнятий
тими чи іншими позиціями знову ж таки
хотів би розказати вам про рядок це ря
це дуже така пвк відкрита Польова
польове укріплення як корек переклад але
з другої сторони Я вас дуже прошу
зрозуміти що сьогодні Міністерство
освіти і власне в нашій позашкільні
центри дуже багато працюють на кого ви
національно-патичному Русі і цей
національний патріотичний рух показуйте
на нашій презентації А зараз
в нас дозволу нема демонстрації екрана
майбуть будь ласка дозвіл є
дозвіл вам але зараз хотів би вам це
свідчити роботу Міністерства освіти це
створення Кібер руху для підлітків
культури тобто йде Future якщо
перекласти це майбутнє і в даному
випадку я хотів би показати перші слайди
цього цього поділитися цього заходу який
пропонується по всіх екологом
туристичних центрів і всі отримання
освіти що має бути майбуть одним із
кроків які я називаю крок про
неможливість зупинити те що рухається а
як за
зайняти дітей у тому розумінні що вони
мусять щось робити інше і в даному
випадку прошу вас дальше про проект
про створення власних блоків кожній
кожного школяра який вільний відділень
ми говоримо про те що
створення підлітків і власник сторінок
блогерів призму здорова нації майбутнє
України на телеграм-каналах ми говоримо
про те що залучення великої кількості де
дітей у просування власного теограм
каналу і створення якісного контенту для
сучасних підлітків Ми так і без руху яку
пропонує ми це покращення стану
навколишнього середовища через безпечний
кі простір налагодження нових знайомств
серед учасників через спільну ідею і
мету тобто іде розуміння що завдання
Кібер руху навчити однолітків друзів
використовувати інтернет правильно і
безпечно ми вважаємо чи тільки в цьому
Ми можемо перемогти про ці субкультури
які рухаються По
сьогоднішніх просторах я єдине що хочу
підтримати колеги яка говорила з
Кіровоградської області що неможливість
закриття наших позашкільних закладів це
один із кроків можливого зацікавлення
школярів нашої роботи ну як можна на
сьогоднішній день закріпити
Закарпатський центр який це був Оазис і
сьогодні його немає як можна було
Хмельницький центр розкрутити Це була
крепость позашкілля крепость якого
металістичної роботи крепості
екологічної трудового виховання як бо ви
розумієте сьогодні йде
Вінницької області де хобі школярів
фактично в трудовому вихованні
екологічної освіти закривається Я вас
дуже Шановні колеги за великим дня того
що в нас дуже мало часу хотів би ще раз
попросити іберпростір - Це страшенна
штука і все і кіберпростором треба
працювати нам треба працювати
упереджено створити створювати в нашій
центр кіберцентри Які би
упереджено працювали на субкультури які
рухаються по Україні це не тільки ця
субкультура сьогодні нас дуже цікавить
осіб попередній план по 7 це зверніть
увагу це збір інформації з чищення даних
та аналіз чистих даних із чистих джерел
для школярів можуть допомагати наші
контррозвідки виявляти цих страшенний
боротьбі яка йдеться сьогодні з
фашистами тих людей які справді твори ли
на українську говорити на Україні
величезні негативні справи Я би дуже
попросив би захоплювати школярів осіб
програмами і в даному випадку все інше в
мене висвітлено на нашому
Дякуємо за доповідь за вашу Володимир
валентиновичу
коли Віра Борисівна і Олег Вікторович
переключились на іншу нараду Я продовжую
до слова запрошується шкура Геннадій
Анатолійович директор Українського
Державного центру позашкільної освіти
Дякую Вадим Миколайович Доброго дня
шановні колеги я не буду повторювати
слова попередніх
доповідачів ораторів Але скажу що ми для
себе в українському державному центрі
розділили цю історію
на два таких
великих розділи це
інструменти
які
використовують при використанні цієї
технології
зокрема телеграм і інші там соціальні
мережі І
власне контент на який ми можемо
впливати тому
[музика]
стосовно почну з контента і стосовно
цього хотів би зауважити Наступне Що ми
для себе
зрозуміли давно що
молодіжну субкультуру заборонити
неможливо у всіх спробах заборонити
субкультуру завжди перемагала
субкультура чи то був брейк-данс чи то
був хіп-хоп чи зараз оцей рядом але ну
походження його з аніме субкультури і ми
для себе
задали питання ще
три роки назад в 19-му році що
створюючи національну субкультуру ми
Таким чином створюємо альтерна
альтернативу в позашкільній освіті всім
цим загрозам які можуть іти з інтернету
з пабліків з телеграмі соціальних мереж
тощо тому ми стали учасниками в нас в
країні є
спеціальний захід який на якому
представлені всі є субкультури які є в
нас України і він називається
фестиваль комікон і нашої
лабораторією Київ грати історичною
реконструкції давнього Київської Русі Ми
взяли участь в цьому фестивалі не просто
а як учасники і тим самим задекларували
що історичну реконструкція і наші
історичні події наша українська історія
національної ідентичність може бути тою
альтернативою і такою самою національною
субкультурою в цьому контексті
ми не тільки взяли участь в цьому
фестивалі ми задекларували те що ми є ми
задекларували нашу
ідентичні тим самим виховуючи
громадянина країни
національно-патріотичне виховання і всі
похідні речі які за цим ідуть
інша історія яка впливає на цей процес є
от те вже Про що говорили колеги це
кібербезпека який берегігієна тобто для
цього В нас теж Ми пішли нетрадиційним
шляхом А ми
використовуючи наш конкурс
stem-освіти
stem-проектів на яких діти представляють
це створили секцію кібербезпеки і в
номінації кібербезпеки протягом
останніх 5 років коли дозволяла безпека
вас ситуація а ми розмовляли що таке
кібербезпека кібергі гігієна і розуміє
заходи треба робити для того щоб не
потрапити в таку ситуацію в якій ми
зараз з вами є для того щоб
поглиблювати цю історію ми нашими
заходами Я думаю що вам Вадим
Миколайович в кінці розійшли весь план
заходів який був розроблений на
реагування цієї ситуації з рідоном
Розказує що
ми проводимо буквально завтра 8 числа
таку цікаву зустріч в рамках нашого
нашої нашого проекту і історичної
реконструкції
київград зустрічі з людиною яка
займається історією яка є
дуже фаховою людиною і написала
книжку приго марка у княжому граді Тобто
це така історія яка теж втягує нас в
історичні події які відбуваються в нашій
країні створюючи цю мальтернативу в
межах цієї розмови з цією людиною
відбудеться обговорення в тому числі і
субкультур і в тому числі що таке є
власна історична реконструкція і наша
власна історія з огляду на ці
субкультури Ще одна історія пов'язана з
історико-рольовим фестивалем шляховий
камінь який відбудеться у нас Ми
сподіваємося офлайн влітку 24 червня де
буде
застосовані окрім всіх розмов ще
імреалізації через історичний фехтування
метання ножів окрім того Це просто
цікаво для дітей це ще й такий
психологічний момент де можна вимістити
свою ту енергію позитивну негативну от в
таких корисних справах і традиційно наш
фестиваль
stem-освіти ай талант він теж
відбудеться і в другій половині березня
буде анонс цього і все як це буде
відбуватися Ну і в кінці
моєї розмови я хотів би продемонструвати
вам
таке невеличке відео яке демонструє от
Саме те про що я казав в контексті нашої
участі у фестивалі комікон
це Дякую колеги Дякуємо шановні Геннадій
Анатолійович дуже цікавий досвід Шановні
колеги я також Хочу наголосити Що в чаті
ми надаємо покликання наші колеги на
ресурси які ви можете також
використовувати у роботі
Також ми напевно підготуємо
інформаційний пакет пакет за
результатами нашої сьогоднішньої наради
щоби і ще раз вам надати доступ
запрошується
до презентації
своєї роботи і
я Хочу наголосити на тому що
важливо використовувати досвід
партнерських організацій які мають уже
досвід напрацювання І от якраз про такі
досвід зараз розкаже
представник
українського державного центру
Національного патріотичного виховання
Бондарчук Денис Олегович прошу
Доброго дня шановні колеги я розумію що
час уже вичерпаний тому я дуже коротко
про наш досвід питань питаннях
кібербезпеки
Ми звичайно розуміємо що дітей Ми не
заберемо з кіберпростору Тому нам треба
якомога
більше захищати їх від небезпечного
впливу Тому ми пішли
таким шляхом цю роботу ми організували в
двох як кажуть напрямках це
один напрямок теоретичний інший
практичний і реалізовано я на прикладі
гри Сокіл джураам коротенько це розкажу
ми реалізовуємо завдяки партнерській
співпраці з різними організаціями Отже
щодо теоретичного напрямку це
наші партнери із
молодіжного центру громадянської освіти
це 9 молодіжних громадських організацій
які
реалізовують багато проектів які
стосуються
медіаграмотності інформаційної гігієни і
безпечного поводження в просторі тому
завдяки такій співпраці ми даємо широки
можливості брати участь у лекціях і
тренінгу нашим учасникам гри Сокіл Джура
І що стосується
практичного напрямку 28 лютого відбулося
черго засідання головного штабу гри
Сокіл Джура куди ми запросили
організаторів всеукраїнського конкурсу
кіберкозак який проводиться щорічно У
рамках національного місяця кібербезпеки
це представники
торгово-промислової палати України і
Київської малої Академії Наук
там була велика презентація і ми
попередньо домовилися про
те що наші Джури зможуть взяти участь у
цьому всеукраїнському конкурсі
там досить цікава програма і всі вікові
категорії від 6 до 18 років там можуть
брати участь І я так думаю що в
подальшому
це все може вирости як кажуть У новий
напрямок гри
Джура Кібер козак і розвивати цей
напрямок
в нашому середовищі і серед наших жор
Дякую
Дякуємо Денис Олегович за цікаву
інформацію
Шановні колеги у
обговоренні питаннях відповідях
зголосилися попереднього виступити
Ольга хмельова з міста Київ
представниця інституту післядипломної
освіти
щиро вам дякую дякую за можливість
проговорити
думаю важливі питання які сьогодні ми
обговорюємо Справа в тому що
те що сьогодні відбувається з
нашими підлітками це не сьогодні
почалось і я завжди кажу що наші діти це
дзеркало нашого суспільства і те що нам
потрібно
сьогодні не просто
з зробити більше від психологічних
психологів від
позашкільників Тобто їх Скажімо так до
себе запросити більше їх але ще інша
сторона - це про стосується саме
такої дуже важливою частиною як
спілкування з батьками я не пам'ятаю
жодного підлітка який би сказав що я
хочу не спілкуватися з батьками вони
кажуть про те що дуже хочемо поміняти
стиль спілкування Ми хочемо щоб нас
почули і тому саме наші діти сьогодні
йдуть шукати підтримку там де Ну скажемо
не дуже підтримка а там де використання
по суті їх оцих бажань бути в
конкурентними бути підтриманими бути
такими що Їх бачать і дійсно з ними
будуть спілкуватися за останні тиждень
Ми практично в місті Києві зробили
декілька таких заходів Особисто я
зустрілася з батьками в декільники
закладах по запиту Скажімо так з
батьками і саме про те про відносини
батьки і діти і я стикнулась з тим що
багато батьків задають питання А як
налагодити стосунки а як покарати а як
іще щось тобто ці питання які стоять
сьогодні на першому місці
наступне - це робота з психологічною
службою і ми провели такий Захід Як
називається називався він так Це
професійний психологічний калейдоскоп ми
запросили голову секції дитячо-юнацьки
психотерапевтів української спілки
психотерапевтів це кандидат вивчив
Вибачте доктор
психологічних наук Галина католик вона
якраз зупинилась на своїх дослідженнях
які були зроблені в декількох і вона
говорила про те наскільки сьогодні є
відношення до життя відношення до смерті
до ризикової поведінки і так далі Тобто
ми провели таке практичне Скажімо так
безпосередньо роботу та а потім
зібрались на круглий стіл і ось там такі
звучали пропозиції наших дітей треба
більше
запрошувати до яких ось таких
підліткових волонтерських загонів коли
людина допомагає іншому вона відчуває
себе сильною вона виключуває себе та яка
вона
важлива да тобто я ще щось роблю щось
корисно роблю і ми бачимо приклади таких
дітей які дійсно можуть
Працюють як волонтери вони допомагають
дуже і вони відчувають себе саме
господарями своєї країни і це є дуже
важлива частинка яку ну безпосередньо
можна зробити що стосується інституту
післядипломної освіти на сьогоднішній
день ми запланували декілька таких саме
вебінарів і очних семінарів
безпосередньо це про небезпечні квести
про як дітей взагалі
якій Які Які взагалі є
Скажем так
не просто квести а ще й неформальне
об'єднання Чому діти туди ідуть І як це
не просто попередити а перш за все
зрозуміти як ми можемо допомогти дитині
зрозуміти де мої іде добро а те зло і це
є стає в першому місці тому я дуже дякую
за сьогоднішню зустріч І дійсно
матеріали які ми отримали от від поліції
Київської області Я дуже вдячна тому що
ці матеріали Я знаю дуже багато хто взяв
саме для роботи Дуже дякую за це і дякую
за те що сьогодні ми зібрались і
поговорити ці нагальні питання Ми
плануємо теж провести такий велику такий
велику нараду там де Запрошуємо і
психологів соціальних педагогів і
освітян для того щоб ми проговорили саме
про те як ми можемо сьогодні допомогти
нашим підліткам саме знайти свій шлях
який не буде шкодити їх життю і шкодити
взагалі їх
відношення ну взагалі до суспільства і
як не викликати від суспільства
негативне це теж дуже важливо
Таким чином я думаю що ми все ж таки
либоротися дійсно казали про те що
боротися з неформальним об'єднаннями
просто не має сенсу Я спілкуюсь з
неформальними різними об'єднаннями вже
дуже давно і колись це були готи колись
це було емо і
там представники синіх китів і так далі
і скажу чесно